mon général j'ai beaucoup apprécié votre
votre intervention et je dois vous
avouer que j'ai beaucoup de respect et
d'admiration pour le travail réalisé par
le RSMA en Guyane aussi sachez
d'ailleurs que je milite pour le retour
du service militaire en outreemère en
tous les cas chez moi en guyan mais en
attendant j'aimerais savoir si vous
envisagez d'ouvrir un RSMA au RSMA de
guyan des sections susceptibles
d'accueillir les jeunes filles mères
comme cela existe
vous le savez votre territoire est
dynamique il va y avoir une bascule
d'effort certainement entre Cayenne et
le Grand Ouest guyanaet au regard de
l'accélération de la population ce qui
fait que finalement le choix qui a été
fait en 2009 d'implanter le SMA
définitivement à Saint-Jean était plutôt
une bonne idée tout en conservant un
pôle akayenne ce régiment fera
l'objet d'une montée en puissance qui
sera est bien entendu à la capacité que
nous avons à construire pour accueillir
l'objectif ici étant de permettre aux
jeunes d'être dans de bonnes conditions
d'accueil pour suivre leur formation ça
commence par la formation militaire
initiale mais également dans les unités
élémentaires dans le plan horizon 2030
il y a un item pour les jeune mè
célibataire parce qu'on sait que ça
représente une population an une
population qui est souvent parce qu'elle
a été maèire très jeune
peu diplômé et donc nous avons nous
cherchons les meilleurs moyens pour
accueillir ces jeunes mères célibataires
et de faire en sorte qu'ell soit là
aussi avec leurs enfants donc
aujourd'hui vous avez un premier projet
majeur qui est en cours de construction
encore en gouellelou vous allez me dire
d'une crèche avec un certain nombre de
lit partagés entre le régiment et la
commune de
bmao et qui permet d'accueillir ces
jeunes fillilles de les loger sur
place de pouvoir les déposer le matin
aller suivre leur formation et récupérer
l'enfant dans une structure un peu
particulière puisque les horaires ne
sont pas celles d'une crèche habituelle
mais adapté au rythme de vie de la jeune
femme donc en guyan bien entendu ça fera
l'objet d'une démarches particulière
conduit une expérimentation lorsqu'elle
est validée on généralise